But in general, what's happening and now
with this Iran business and the
potential crisis that will happen, which
probably will lead to more migrants
flooding in and this sort of and this,
you know, feeling that people have that
it's now we're obligated to take in more
and more. It's just amazing, like I
said, because when you zoom out and look
at it, the big picture and cuz a lot of
people are very myopic and they just
think in the now, they're very
temporal-minded.
And they can look in their city, let's
say in the UK, and it's still what?
Under 10% Muslim. So, in their mind,
that's not a big deal, but it actually
is a big deal when you really understand
how it's happening progressively. And I
saw a Pew report that said that by 2050,
Germany is set to be about 20% Muslim.
And that's without any more immigration,
just based on
demographic growth of what's already
there.
So, it's just amazing that, you know,
this the continent of Europe, which was
essentially the the final historic
bastion of Christianity and, you know,
the well, the white race, and now it's
being essentially,
taken over both by the Islamic religion
and by peoples from around the from the
third world, essentially.
>> All right, man, let's go to France for a
second.
A 23-year-old young right-wing Catholic,
Quentin Derang, was murdered by a group
of French Antifa. And this has caused
shockwaves throughout French politics
because the the Antifa group was
connected to La France Insoumise, which
is a far-left party. There have been
protests in favor of Quentin, in memory
of Quentin. And we have next year the
presidential election coming up in
France. This is all gone to the benefit
of the Rassemblement National, the
former National Front. What do you see
when you look at France and the
Islamization of politics and the
Islamo-leftist
movement. I see everywhere every
everywhere is headed civil war to be
honest with you. That's that's the only
kind of
the culmination of what's going on.
Either that or one group acquiesces and
capitulates namely to give them whatever
in you know parlance or speaking in
American or Europe but you know normal
people I'll put it that way okay then
the natives either they have to
capitulate or there's going to be
essentially war because again going back
to the numbers and the growing
demographic population explosion of
Muslims and migrants and so forth. What
are you going to do when it's 50%? I
mean or 60%? Now you're an absolute
minority. If 10% is creating so much
havoc, what's going to happen when it's
30% which is very realistic and you know
not too far from the horizon. So I think
and we're already seeing this I think in
the UK there's this new party
reform Britain I think. And the and the
language coming out is very you know
it's it's in on the one hand it's
refreshing because it's kind of language
that is needed. On the other hand it's
pretty militant.
You know he's they're not just talking
about stopping migration. They're
talking about
reversing it which means we're actually
going to send which but you know is that
bad? No I think that is actually
necessary. That's the point they're in
but once they get to that point the
other side's not going to just give in
either. So this is just going to become
a massive conflict
literally of of civil war.
>> One thing I've been talking about a lot
for the last year is the prospect of
civil war in Britain and in continental
Europe.
>> What else is the toothpaste that has
come out of the tube that has
dramatically affected society but we
can't get it back out? To me it would be
a little more abstract and more
philosophical. It would actually be the
thing that connects everything. You
mentioned how migration is the big one
but what else? And it's just it's it has
different names. You know they call it
the left leftist thinking wokeism. I
think which all of this of course and
when it's all condensed is a
philosophical worldview that is
essentially it's almost like a virus
that has taken over especially Western
type people and it's become you know
it's what degrades them and breaks them
down and makes them susceptible to all
sorts of things. If you look at again
the migrant
>> that What is that philosophy? But if you
look at the migrant crisis for example
that's all self-made as one example.
It's It's a self-made problem. That's
why Hungary
Victor Orban can you know be this nation
that's not as powerful as Western Europe
or the UK or France and it doesn't have
this issue because he simply put up a
fence which they could have done but
because of this mind virus. So well like
I said it has different names you know
they call it the left. Well I mean What
What What would you call it? Well
globalism you know humanitarian
universalism.
>> No no I'm thinking more of the an act
leftism okay
the leftist mentality. I don't want to
use the word liberal because liberal is
good but extreme liberalism wokeism. All
of this has just short-changed the way
people think clearly.
>> that back.
>> And yeah so I think that's the big genie
that out of the bottle that needs to be
you know be brought back in to use your
my version of your analogy.
>> Yeah. On that happy note gentlemen thank
you for joining us today. Bring back
the flame.
Bring back the
>> [music]
>> Bring back the
fire
>> [music]
>> and the righteousness.